Edgar farther this is great Edgar farted
maybe dance let's do a dance yeah yeah
girl get a girl
big it farted is it with the style this
is how ducks [ __ ] because they have
corkscrew penises ha ha
what where can't imagine where magic
happens
miji watch me right here where should we
write your [ __ ] I don't stop trying to
kill me [ __ ] you
you're never never try to smack that
booty
yeah gear why are you healing so much
[ __ ] yous make that kill the midgets I
maintain I meant I meant little people
oh my god alright mushes help
what are you doing everything key you
shall not pass there's so many [ __ ]
spells how does how do you even like ah
what the [ __ ] happened well surrender yo
man
thanks Brett ok wait you got a shield oh
yeah there's a shield get put it on yeah
you just shield yourself
you
look at this no problem
easy no problem no problem hey where the
[ __ ] am I guess guess that's me you're
the [ __ ] pity pie doing
[ __ ] you put it back yeah okay awesome
how am I still alive I understand I'm so
confused
I'm on fire I'm on fire I was going to
water hi drown [ __ ] sake [ __ ] sake I'm
so oh my god kill him
use a definite revive me not PewDiePie
er revive me both everybody I'll put a
pie he's an imposter [ __ ] fake-ass
[ __ ] oh cool
dude that's that's cool I'll have to
wait on him
fasik hello how are you your own I don't
understand anything
oh my god PewDiePie you're such a [ __ ]
you're ruining everything okay okay yeah
[ __ ] that [ __ ] hate PewDiePie stupid
videos you know all he does is yell and
that was just makes rape jokes yeah what
the [ __ ] is going on
anything widget hey you can take the
bottle carried it kill Hockaday kill
hockey dude get out you're good
dance dance dance I'm on fire wait this
freakin PewDiePie live again yeah got a
God dang it where is it I can't sleep
with this huge I'm [ __ ] hate put a
pie there is look at him just waiting
[ __ ] you [ __ ] filled on the table yeah
yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ]
right am i right am i right right right
am i right am i right all right yeah
stop
love you did won't this p2p how do you
heal like a [ __ ] boss take a rock
here without sin ah Wow oh I thought you
were put a pie oh my god I'm so sorry
nice cut I Spit I started don't you know
with these eyes I swear I swear I would
never I would know ha ha [ __ ] sake can
ya now tell em have a dance party hey we
can't have a dance party yeah yeah
pretty pie yeah
you're so nice hey but they mix religion
sometimes really low a gap which is
flame I guess do you understand some
words I do yeah much like you just like
you're killing them and they like what
yeah they're Swedish fuck'em burn in
hell kill the swedish birds don't kill
the sweet version they're my friends I
changed my mind I'm sorry I'm sorry
Swedish people shame lightly I will heal
you I will heal you my friend how'd you
do the beam don't worry about it frame
don't kill my Swedish friends they won't
give you meatballs now they were gonna
give us meatballs can friend I don't die
Freud over Jane don't die Frodo touch me
there Frodo Sam Sam Sam I'm healing you
100%
I'm so healed you're the best healer
ever Hank that's some pretty sick
healing there keeps me yeah
you
okay let me do a kissing spell Oh rabbit
know where I'll heal you friends go
along Swedish people hold you with you
we can combine our streams hmm don't
cross the streams now let's combine them
combined become I don't heal but what do
you do I think we cross this we don't
cross hey do it again
okay well Lizzie's here hey Hill oh you
want to hear them to death okay that's a
great idea
come on man come on man we gotta kill
him hurry ever cross the stream cross my
stream Brook you're using the wrong with
our powers combined I just I just clips
okay wait wait wait don't don't approach
don't approach now we combine our
streams
I used the flame you you keel okay one
okay you combine it not there you idiot
there it is teamwork
it's is that hard it is it's hard to a
with Wisma stick
we must you know uh-huh when you combine
the strings it's hard to get towards Amy
okay so combine combine this dreams
right now okay is really fast combine
this dreams ah alright alright we're
gonna have to cross streams are you
ready are you ready I got sick DPS going
look at that [ __ ] those sick deeps gotta
get dots up more dots more dots
oh man look at this DPS bruh
prevents me and that was the end of pity
path taken down by gigantic crab March
day
I'd never to be seen again make fertile
he came back I cry every crack hey Sam
be Sam be your [ __ ] yeah so real get
Rick [ __ ]
[Music]
it is holder No